hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
effective implementation strategies
reduce unnecessary procalcitonin testing
while improving outcomes how to be an
expert
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit procalcitonin.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation i'd like to
now welcome our speaker
mike broyles pharmd director of pharmacy
and laboratory services at st bernard's
five rivers medical center in arkansas
dr boyles you may now begin your
presentation
okay well thank you very much and i
would love to thank everyone and you
know lab roots and thermal fisher for
allowing to speak to you to you guys
today i think we'll have a lot of fun
and hopefully find some useful
information so objectives today i would
like for you to understand the
biochemistry and kinetics of
procalcitonin in bacterial infection so
procasal tone is a test that needs to be
understood and so to apply the concepts
it's incredibly important to understand
it's not a pregnancy test yes no it's
not a simple test and there's a lot of
nuances that go along with it
describe how to implement order sets and
protocols so that you can optimize test
utilization this is one of the most
effective ways to implement the use of
procalcitonin
and then explore best practices for a
successful procalcitonin adoption
where you can actually have be very
confident in the clinical outcomes and
the use of procalcitonin and you know
the problem is within lab is a lot of
times we have a lot of testing that we
do we resolve a test but
if it doesn't get acted on then that's a
problem so one of the keys is that we
want to make sure that when we do this
test that we get the value for it and
that's one of the things that we want to
talk about today and then we want to
cite the data supporting pct aided
antimicrobial stewardship and lower
respiratory tract infections and sepsis
so those are the fda indications
why is antibiotic stewardship negan i'm
just going to spend just a couple of
minutes to describe
and kind of drive home the point i hope
about antimicrobial use so it is said by
the cdc that up to the half of the
antibiotics we use in a hospital in the
acute care setting is considered
inappropriate and what's interesting
about that is that
this number has been out there for more
than 20 years and so we know it's a
problem
and we talk about it but we really
haven't been able to address it we
haven't really made any clinical inroads
as far as we're doing a better job
now let me give you an example so in the
recent code data
the initial data said 8 to 12 had a
bacterial co-infection and then that
basically 72 to 83 percent received
antimicrobial therapy now the only
reason to ever give antibiotics in the
code in a patient is if you had a
secondary bacterial infection so the
original data said eight to twelve
percent but yet almost nine and ten got
antibiotic therapy and so obviously
there's a problem and now we know that
the secondary bacterial infection is
actually closer to four percent so we
continue to overuse antibiotics
now this is an interesting paper that
was published this was in march of this
year and they looked at commons
prescribing habits and hospitalized
patients with gap and urinary tract
infection this was a large sample size
192 hospitals and so overall all
indications they found that 55.9
i'm gonna round if that's okay sixty
percent of antibiotic use was considered
inappropriate and the community acquired
pneumonia it was almost eighty percent
again inappropriate think about that
that is four out of five or basically
eight out of ten depending on how you
want to look at that urinary tract
infection on emission
76.8 was considered inappropriate and
then when we look at patients prescribed
fluoroquinolones 46 and a half percent
got added fluoroquinolones when it was
not recommended and then patients
prescribed iv vancomycin was 27.3 not
recommended and i actually thought that
number would be a little higher um
vancomycin is a problem area for me it's
like
everybody that comes in has mrsa for
some reason
now just in case um
you think i'm being a little dramatic
look at these articles this is article
after article
after article
and after article these are all recent
publications that talks about the
overuse of antimicrobials in covert
nineteen and basically this thing can be
said during uh seasonal influenza back
when we actually reported those cases of
it now why do we care well we care
because it's estimated by the year 2050
the leading cause of death will be
antimicrobial resistant bacteria which
it will be in excess of 10 million
patients so this is not going to happen
overnight it's not like somebody flips a
switch but it's going to continue to get
worse and so even if you don't die what
happens if you had a scratch in your leg
and you ended up being below the knee
amputee or something like that these are
very great concerns and then others
there's a lot there's kidney injury
there's a lot of things i've just picked
a couple c difficile infections there
are now well over half a million
hospitalizations due to c death each
year
and then this antibiotics increase the
risk of c difficile associated uh
diarrhea by seven to ten times while
receiving the antibiotics
and for up to one month later
so this is a huge concern less is better
if we can do that one in six who get
infected with c def will get it again in
a subsequent two to eight weeks that's
very concerning and it gets worse
so in eighty percent of the deaths occur
in these patients who are age 65 or
greater and then this is very sobering
within one month of diagnosis one in 11
people over the age of 65 died from c
difficile associated diarrhea it's
gravely concerning
so when we have to ask our question is
if we know that we're using more
antibiotics why do we do that i think
the answer is very simple it's always
error in favor of caution we do it
just to be sure and i think that's a
very common thing
and so why are other things obviously
there's a lot of indications where we
have overlapping clinical symptoms if
you think about congestive heart failure
copd exacerbations community acquired
pneumonia those chest films and some of
those things basically
it's difficult to know and then it's
also hard to know is it viral versus
bacterial and that's one of the key
concepts and so think about this the p
the problem has always been that
biomarkers with low sensitivity and
specificity have been around and so then
finally in the end we have the overlap
just to be sure because basically all
these other things happen
and so
if we look at the biomarkers that we
commonly have where we look at white
count we look at sensitivity and
specificity so specificity bacteria for
a white count is extremely low basically
it's just uh it's a gas because it's
elevated in any circumstance sensitivity
inflammation very high there are 596
drugs or diseases can affect the white
count c reactive protein is actually
more specific but again much of the same
problems in its kinetics are very
different lactate has nothing to do with
that i mean it's a marker of
hypoperfusion
temp 1180 things that can drive a temp
up or down and so the nice thing is is
that procalcitonin is considered to be
94 specific for bacteria and that's why
it's different
so the question then becomes we've
studied over 1800 biomarkers for
infection what makes procalcitonin
different and this is a key concept i
just want you to grasp this concept
all parenchymal tissues so all tissues
within the body have what we call a
tolecra receptor and as you recall
there's all kinds of toe-like receptors
we have at least 12 that have been
elucidated
and so
as depicted by this little purple nubby
that is the toll-like receptor anything
bacterial then can affect or activate
the toll-like receptor and once that
happens two things take place
we actually get the immediate release of
interleukin-1 interleukin-6 to necrosis
factor because they are stored in the
cell and they are released immediately
so that's where we get that immediate
rise in those inflammatory markers that
we're so familiar with
the other thing that happens is very
very important is is that a signal is
sent to the cell to
make procalcitonin so this is very
important procalcitonin is not stored it
has to be made and that process takes
three to six hours okay very very
important point so once that toll-like
receptor causes pro-calcitonin to be
geared up and made usually we can
measure within three to six hours but
the important concept is is that there
is nothing
both the drug and the word
state that can keep you from making
procalcitonin and that's a very
important concept if you have bacteria
you will make
procalcitonin the other thing is very
important is now remember this tolecra
receptor has to be activated by bacteria
for it to elevate and hence from this we
have the inability of viruses to
actually elevate pct and there's
actually a negative feedback mechanism
with interferon so in this situation
procalcitonin is never elevated in a
pure viral infection and so this drives
home that concept think about this so
for the first time ever if you have to
activate the tollock receptor the more
toll-like receptors that are activated
the higher the pct level the more
bacteria you have and so for the first
time ever we have a tool to tell us
about the severity of illness the other
thing is just to drive home the concept
is pct has never elevated a pure viral
infection
it can tell you about the bacterial
burden at a point in time
it doesn't reveal the location we have
to find that diagnostically but that
change over time can help us know our
antibiotics working and then do we have
opportunities many times to stop sooner
and that's very important
so in the procalcitonin we would say
that a normal value is 0.1 or less and
that's what we're showing here is a
normal value
in that 0.1 to 0.5 that's considered a
localized infection there's not a lot of
systemic release of pct
and then most hospitals will report two
alert value and they report 10 as a
critical value these numbers can go as
high as a thousand we've had people in
dic and necrotizing status that have
been in the 900s 700s 550s and so on so
these values can be very very high
there's not a magical number which a
patient is in sepsis severe sepsis or
septic shock okay that is a syndrome
okay the higher the number the greater
cause for concern
so also prognostically that's very
important the higher the number and then
failure for that pct to go down is
prognostically and not good and so
there's a lot of information that can be
garnered from the initial pct value
so kind of in summary we said that pct
rises in the first three to six hours
it's what we see here we can see that
it's time to peak once that toll-like
receptor is activated it's a biphasic
peak is basically say 24 so once your
body sees bacteria it makes pct for 24
hours its elimination half life is also
24 hours so this is really nice it's
easy to remember these numbers and then
based on its elimination half life the
most effective time to evaluate the
therapy and the effectiveness of your
therapy is also 24 hours so rises in
three to six fixing 24
elimination half life 24 best time to
evaluate the effectiveness of your
therapy it's also 24. so what you can
actually see for instance if we had a
pcp value of 10 we apply appropriate
antibiotic therapy 24 hours passes then
what we would what would we expect the
pct value to be
well we would expect it to be about half
because it goes down by about half every
24 hours okay
so the role of procasatonin in
stewardship okay
antimicrobial stewardship quite simply
is the appropriate use of antibiotics we
need to know a couple of things is this
infection viral or bacterial because pct
has never elevated a viral infection so
very useful
if it's bacterial do we need antibiotics
just because you have a bacterial
infection if pct is very low it doesn't
require the use of antibiotics okay it
can help you establish bacterial burden
or the severity of infection
and that you can help you evaluate are
the antibiotics the correct choice with
two serial measurements are my
antibiotics working and then many times
how long to treat can i stop early based
on an absolute value or an 80 reduction
so
this is why
the body requires bacteria to make pct
that's an important concept just an
inflammatory response only does not
cause pct to be made and that's very
important
so let's use i'm going to just show you
two case studies and give you some value
of pct so this is an interesting case
it's a 56 year old male construction
worker and asthma since childhood it's a
smoker very important
chief complaint shortness of breath
productive cough malaise and fever this
has been going on for a while and of
course he got his impact because
everybody gets a z-pack the steroids
work for his asthma so when he presents
the temps not bad blood pressure's
normal pulses 90 respiratory rate's 20.
he's 92 percent on room air with a white
count of just fourteen seven six percent
bands chest found says though early
bilateral pneumonia so the plan was to
put him on levofloxacin
now
let me ask you a question
if i told you his pct on admission was
0.7
remember that point you know 1
ish to 0.5 is fairly low 2 is alert 10
is critical
0.7 doesn't seem that
bad
now if i told you pct was 15 where you
know two's alert 10's a critical value
does it seem like he has a lot more
bacteria and at this point in time with
our discussion i hope your answer would
be yes and so this is why you do pct in
the ed it's very important to get the
baseline and it tells you something
about the initial severity of assessment
in this case we're actually going to
start at 0.7 okay
we can see his pct is 0.7 he is placed
on levofloxacin right
now the next day notice what happens in
the blue the pct goes from 0.7 to 36.
now this has been right at 24 hours and
this was um
years ago we've been using pct for 11
years and i've looked at a lot of pct
values and so when we went to the
clinician early on we said you know pct
has gone up very significantly this is
huge cause for concern
can we please change therapy and he
would not do that he said i look at
passion he just needs more time for the
antibiotics to work well the antibiotics
that don't begin to work in 24 hours
they're never going to work that's one
thing that you can bank on and that was
unfortunate because the next day what
happened is his pct went from 36 to 86
at that point in time we actually
changed his therapy and he was placed on
maripin and vancomycin so this was this
was very
concerning obviously had we not waited
that 24 hours to change his therapy
things might have been different with
him
and so then we actually had a sputum
that was positive for gram-positive
lancet shape
diplococci same for blood cultures with
a lot of white cells so obviously we
think we know what's going on here he
probably has a start pneumo
and then
one of the things we did do is we
repeated that pct in 12 hours which we
don't normally do but in this case we
want to make sure that it was trending
down
and then day three we can actually see
it we actually went from 86 to 46 that's
over 24 hour time frame telling us our
antibiotics are working
and so
very interesting then speedup on was
positive for streptococcus pneumoniae so
this is blood cultures now with
levofloxacin we normally are 97 98
but i guess he was one of the ones that
was not within that range and so he was
one of the you know the two or three
percent and so as we follow this out you
can see that the pct continued to go
down by about half
and then based on the fda fda algorithm
you can actually stop antibiotics when
you have an 80 reduction in pct
and so that would be at the end of day
five there's really no need to continue
to
give this man antibiotics you don't have
to go longer than that in this case now
let me give you um
and make it very clear the diagnosis of
pneumonia is based on the three pillars
or the symptoms they had clinical
symptoms tissue infiltrates
uh you know inflammation suspicion of
infection pct does not have to be hugely
elevated
but there are certain circums certain
circumstances where about a third of
your patients will have pct that's
basically around point
the reason is is that the naughtiest of
the infection within the lung can be
fairly small
and one of the things is is that
atypical organisms mycoplasma chloramine
chlamydia pneumoniae because they're
atypical they do not induce a lot of pct
so obviously it's not that common of
infection but in those situations you
don't have a hugely elevated pct but
anytime you have a significant elevation
in pct it doesn't go down after the
first 24 hours we need to think in terms
of stopping or changing therapy
now this is kind of an interesting thing
i want to put this in perspective for
you
as far as other markers and that the
information that pct can give you so um
this lady was admitted 67 year old
female model mental confusion she
complained of basically everything um
you know she was very
non-specific
everything she had hurt because she had
fibromyalgia okay very common complaint
she had a long history of recurrent
urinary tract infections uh hypertension
migraine and depression that otherwise
specified so generally generalized
anxiety these people typically are very
somatic and typically have a long med
list and so this is the ua okay we have
one plus plus leukocyte estrase four to
six white cells bacteria is two plus and
she had this very um concentrated dark
nasty urine now
we have a white count though that's 9.6
62 neutrophils and we have a pct that's
0.05 now she's not against a good
historian she can't really tell us
what's going on and so what's
interesting is is that in the elderly
patients particularly those in the
nursing home 40 percent of those
patients are colonized they're always
going to have a ua that looks like
they're infected and so this is where
you can have value to pct because in a
patient who's colonized pct will not
elevate and so this is what we're
actually seeing so here's what happened
though this is the story
so patient was admitted pct is normal
blood pressure is normal they were
placed on ceftriaxone now the next day
the blood pressure dropped to 90 over
58. so if you come in you're a clinician
and you see this the first thing you're
going to think is what
yeah you're going to think that this
patient has
your sepsis and so they got to lactate
it's 2.7
and then though the pct is still normal
i can tell you that if you have two
negative pct values there's a 99
probability you do not have
a bacterial infection from any shape
form or fashion and so what's kind of
interesting is i got a call from the
clinician we had the discussion and they
insisted on stopping the cetrox and
putting on piptazo and tupper monsoon
because they were worried about this
because she had a long history of
urinary tract infections but you know
the thing is
she doesn't need this there's something
else going on but hypotension and
lactate always equals what in people's
minds it equals sepsis that's
unfortunate because that's not always
the case so we have 10 hours later blood
pressure is still the same
the lactate is now 4.3 and there really
wasn't another pct order but i went and
got one and we pulled it just to drive
home the point you now have three
negative pct's there's no way in the
world this is a bacterial infection but
the discussion was
i want to start adding i want to add
vancomycin well vancomycin you know
it just wasn't necessary so a long story
short what actually happened is is that
we actually got a troponin the troponin
was significantly elevated as was the
ekg and this lady had to go to the cath
lab she was actually having a keto mind
and so because she couldn't tell us and
because she really was non-symptomatic
we were getting information from pct
that was telling us that this is not a
bacterial infection and remember
hypotension alone is not the only
indicator i mean
you know sepsis is not the only
indicator of
of an elevation in lactate it can come
from acute mi it can come from heart
failure and other things and so this
helps us put this in perspective
so let's talk a little bit about the
implementation secrets for success the
goal is to give you a test that will
improve the clinical outcomes for your
patients and yet you get the biggest
bang for the buck and so one of the
things that we have to realize is that
you're dealing with human nature and
this is a very hard because getting
people to start antibiotic therapy is
like pulling a pacifier from somebody's
mouth i mean a baby's mouth it is a hard
thing to do
and many times they don't see any need
to change or they're afraid to change
and they don't want to even though they
know it's the right thing to do and and
then
you know obviously there's those people
that know know more than you do so the
question is will why change and so we
have to think in terms of changing
behavior how what can we do to do that
and this is where we're at
we have to provide enough objective
evidence that there's not an infection
that requires the use of antibiotics so
it's the spiral versus bacterial
we have to prove that
stopping antibiotics earlier is safe and
it's safe in low receptors and or
respiratory tract infections and we've
done that there's tons of literature on
that stopping earlier also we have to
prove will not result in readmissions
one of the hardest things for my
clinicians was with stopping is they
said my 30 day readmission rate is going
to go up and that was not the case it
was actually half as much and they had a
hard time dealing with that
and then we have to unders make them
understand that the outcomes can
actually be better
and it is best for the patient
and for themselves in the hospital so
implementation strategies try to partner
with the antimicrobial stewardship
committee it involves a lot of folks you
have your physicians you have
pharmacy you have infection control you
have laboratory you have a quality you
have all those people there together and
they can help drive better outcomes and
so that's important the key players are
in the pharmacy and the antimicrobial
sturgeon committee we as pharmacists are
tasked with the antimicrobial
stewardship overview and having to have
those committees in place that is our
primary focus it's very helpful if you
have a champion somebody who is on board
with pct and will push and we'll push
that's very useful
but the most successful
indicator is education as i say pct has
a lot of nuances and we haven't even
began to talk about the nuances we just
kind of gave just basically the
background information with pct
so
the easiest way to make people
understand how to use pct is through
case studies
that is the only way clinicians will get
it and it's very important to do that
and then you want to broaden the
educational special nuances what does it
do in autoimmune disease what does it do
in chronic kidney failure what does it
do in acute kidney failure what does it
do in surgery and all these special
nuances to make people understand and
give them the knowledge
i would suggest that you don't start in
the icu many people want to start in the
icu because it's smaller and it seems
more controllable
but remember the people in the icu are
sicker
and the sicker people are the harder it
is to get people to stop antibiotics so
kind of important if you think about
that
again the key is education education
education
every time i've seen pcp not do well
it's failure to get the clinicians
properly trained and that's one of the
key concepts i'll just say it again the
in way the best way is to be
antimicrobial stewardship committee
and start your testing in the ed we just
did a case study where you could see
that it's important pct is a serial test
nobody runs one troponin you don't want
one pct so start at the ed and then
you're going to follow it when they get
emitted
so you're always going to run two serial
measurements you're always going to have
two pct's when if they're admitted to
the hospital the first one and then one
24 hours later that's very very
important
so the other piece is is that of
ordering so that helps if you have
protocol ordering
and if you have prn ordering and what i
mean by that is is that you basically
have protocols to treat patients you
have maybe a community acquired
pneumonia a community acquired pneumonia
protocol you have a sepsis protocol you
have these protocols and they have
things ordered everything that you need
to do and it has ordered
the
what processes need to be ordered and
how often and it's a lot easier if you
put pct in your order sets and also the
pre ordering is also thinking about
who's going to order pct and follow up
with pct when it didn't get ordered
correctly and that will happen sometimes
so
establish your algorithms your protocols
begin with substance and lower
respiratory tract infection that's the
fda approved indications and make sure
that you get the correct interval there
is no need to do a pct on admission and
do one six hours later remember the
ideal time is 24 hours after the initial
pct
i don't want you to do initial testing
that you don't have to do we want to get
the biggest paying for your uh for your
buck
and so
again make sure that somebody is making
sure that there's the appropriate
interval and that somebody is looking at
every test and that's very important and
that they can act on those tests and one
of the ways to do that is through
protocols and for auto stop
considerations we actually have a
protocol in place that says two negative
pcts or an 80 reduction in sepsis and
low respiratory tract infections we auto
stop we do the same thing in uh
in patients who have uh urinary tract
infections or who
got started in the antibiotics and have
a negative pct because they're colonized
so these are opportunities to streamline
your process and to be more effective
and of course it's best if you put these
in your electronic order sets to make
sure that you have consistency in
compliance
one of the easiest things to do when you
start pct early is to give confidence to
your clinicians is to order a pct the
next day so let's say for instance that
today i have an 80 reduction in pct on a
community acquired pneumonia or a copd
exacerbation
antibiotics are stopped today
order a pct tomorrow for and you can do
this for a while and it makes them feel
comfortable in knowing that the pct is
not going up it won't go up i can tell
you within one to two
well with a 98 to 99 certainty it'll
never go up but until they understand
that until they see it you can order a
pct the next day to make them feel more
comfortable
it's also recommended to share the
outcomes when you have better outcomes
because what you're actually going to
see is you're going to have better
clinical outcomes way fewer antibiotics
and a lot less cost and you need to
share that to drive home your
basically your successes and you need to
report these outcomes they can go in p t
they can go into your stewardship they
can go into quality but basically
there's a lot of opportunities for you
to share that information
and then again to re re-educate this is
always going to be continuing process
because you always have people who are
coming in who are new okay who have been
hired you have no use had you know no
experience with pct
um you have people who come in and you
know basically they don't see the value
because they came from somewhere that
they didn't see the value they didn't
look at it but they just thought it was
you know because somebody else did it
was okay
a key concept is this is that believe
the test is very reliable and it's much
more objective than simply looking at a
patient a critically ill patient
two negative pcts i can tell you that
you do not have a bacterial infection i
understand the need to want to continue
but it provides you with a lot of
information
again many diagnoses have very similar
symptoms the question comes down to do
we need antibiotics in these patients so
this is the fda approved indication it
says to aid in decision making on
antibiotic
discontinuation for patients with
suspected or confirmed sepsis and to aid
in decision making on antibiotic therapy
for inpatients of patients in eb with
lower respiratory tract infections which
they definitely define as caps cop
exacerbations and acute bronchitis and
this was actually the algorithm that
came with the fda approval which by the
way only took three months
and so here's the initiation so for
instance if you had a cop exacerbation
pct came in at say 0.2 therapy is
discouraged your body has the ability to
fight off that infection but if bct
comes in at 0.26 to 0.5 it's encouraged
and always strongly encouraged around
the 0.5
antibiotic discontinuation again lower
respiratory tract infections an absolute
value of 0.25 or an 80 drop and it sets
this 0.5 or an 80 drop and notice the
wording this is the fda's wording
cessation strongly encouraged with
clinical improvement okay
now you cannot stop early in all
indications you can't stop early in
endocarditis osteomyelitis skin insulin
structure infections and those who are
on chemotherapy or yeah
or people who have mrsa bacteria because
you're actually trying to prevent
endocarditis but it can be stopped in
these patients
so let's answer questions here so
with the idsa cap guidelines
recommending i use of pct
for initiation
are there scenarios where it might be
useful in cap i think here's the
question let me ask you guys the
question
so if 50 of cap is viral which we know
it is right
does it seem good to treat everyone with
five days of antibiotics that's what
they kind of actually said start
antibiotics on everybody because nothing
has the sensitivity to tell us
does that make sense knowing that one
half of those patients have a viral
infection and i think you would agree
the answer is no it doesn't make any
sense at all now
if a bacterial infection is confirmed
you're very comfortable
does it seem like
five days of antibiotics is the perfect
duration for all patients with
these infections and i think the answer
you would say would be no in fact based
on our data with pct guidance and over
over several thousand patients i can
tell you that a pc a
antibiotic duration of five days based
on pct guidance is
appropriate or is the right duration 13
of the time the remaining part of the
time you're giving antibiotics too long
or too short and so that's very
important to think about
if you grow an organism from the sputum
or from a bronx should you always treat
that organism and that you identify our
lungs are colonized they're full of
bacteria so the question becomes just
because you
grow an organism should you treat it i
fight this all the time i'll have
somebody they'll say
i i grew out of pseudomonas i grew out
of mrsa if the pct is normal i'm saying
you have identified a colonized organ
organism let's not treat them and so
there's a lot of value here
so
this was actually from a medscape review
article and this is what it said
pinpointing the source of infection and
community acquired pneumonia can be a
daunting task that more often not
results in failure although
streptococcus pneumoniae are the most
frequently isolated bacterial pathogens
they are no longer the most common cause
of cat pay attention to this
in fact despite extensive testing no
pathogen is detected in sixty percent of
patients with cap even when a pathogen
is isolated it's usually a virus a rhino
influenza or having human metanemovirus
and this is due in part to the use of
vaccines so this is very very important
if you think about it so now i would
hope you would agree then that the
environment has changed it loves with
opportunities to avoid prescribing in
antibiotics in patients who have pure
viral infections
and so again this just circles back
around
considering and consider starting
antibiotics in the diagnosis of cap
but discontinue with a second normal
value or an a 80 reduction in the
maximal pct value and that's a good uh
rule to go by so this was actually from
the two co-authors of the
most recent ats idsa chess guidelines
and this i'm going to just
circle in on the hone in on the bottom
statement
before the coven 19 pandemic the
inflammatory biomarker procalcitonin was
shown to
safely reduce antibiotic use in patients
with cap and this is what we've always
known and they brought this up so what
about sepsis let's talk about sepsis so
since pct is not specifically listed in
the surviving steps of cms guidelines
why should we use it
let's think about that
so again whole question
patients meeting sepsis criteria are
required to have antibiotics started
immediately regardless of pct value is
that true
yeah unfortunately
it is okay
which is kind of silly
all right because there's a big
difference between sepsis severe sepsis
and septic shock
now if 40 of those patients meeting
sepsis criteria need antibiotics and 60
don't
why would we continue to give
antibiotics in those patients and it's
true people who meet the substance
criteria because that criteria was set
so long
it makes no sense to give these people
continued antibiotics
and
you can safely stop antibiotics and
sepsis patients 24 hours after the
initial value
and then weighs 0.5 or reduced 80
percent from the maximum value and i
hope you would say yes based on our
discussion
so
think about this we're required to start
antibiotics based on the current
guidelines although i wish that would
definitely change 40 percent of the
patients meeting sepsis criteria
actually need antibiotics it's always
pct can help you in that viral versus
bacterial decision
it can help you in the initial severity
assessment it can tell you if your
antibiotics are working and provide
opportunities for early cessation
so kind of the last section is this
does it work does it save you money does
it improve clinical outcomes so this was
a paper that i published in open forum
infectious disease it was the impact of
calcitonin guided antibiotic management
on antibiotic exposure and outcomes and
this is real world evidence so in our
study what you will see is that we had
2152 patients
985 were in our control group 1167 were
in our study group
overall the days of therapy which is the
most accurate measurement of antibiotics
that you can do
we reduced 47 now that's on top of a
mature stewardship program that have
been in place for more than 17 years
so again we reduce antibiotic exposure
47 which i think is very interesting we
reduced hospital all-course mortality by
62
hospital mortality from infection 59
and people look at that and go that
seems high well now think about this put
it in perspective hospital mortality in
u.s hospitals is two percent two and one
hundred people die
if you simply go from two and one
hundred to one to one hundred you just
reduce mortality by
fifty percent so it's very doable
this was a big thing thirty day
all-cause readmissions will reduce 50
readmission from infection 49
and so this is kind of interesting
because
what you can see is that we used half as
many antibiotics but we had
twice as good outcomes so people get how
can that be more is always better no
what is better is is the right amount
and that's where we're at at this point
in time
so hospitals see different cell
infections reduce 64 and that's very
important because you can lose one
percent of your medicare money if your c
difficile rate is too high and then we
saved fifty percent of the adverse
events from metamorphosis and that can
be a very large number if you think
about it
so we presented the data and of course
one of the first things they said well
what about the money
and so we did analysis on that we broke
it down by sepsis and we broke it down
by lrti
and so what you actually can see is is
that we actually reduced antimicrobial
expenditures almost 55 percent
okay we reduced laboratory cost by 32
percent so even running 3.1 pcts per
patient i still save the laboratory
money get that think about that it's the
big concept
and then mechanical ventilation costs
reduced almost 53 percent
and then
we looked at uh
c difficile infections was 30 36
so overall that is a 49 reduction in
cost of the patient now
i think in our society we look at
numbers all the time and we don't
appreciate numbers so let me ask you a
question
if you went to buy a car today or a
truck and you went and the sticker price
said fifty two thousand fifty five
dollars
and the guy walks up to you you know the
flip car salesman and he says
today you can have that card for
thousand six hundred twenty one dollars
would that get your attention
well yeah because that applies to us
that's real money that is very important
when you think of that that is a huge
difference we did the same thing for
lower respiratory tract infections again
antibiotic exposures for almost 47
a laboratory cost almost 22 percent and
c difficile 19 and still that's almost a
25 reduction overall so it's very
significant now let me just show you one
more article this is the meta-analysis
that we published of 13 articles in the
u.s
and i'm showing you this because you
could say well my hospital is a one-off
okay so this was a meta-analysis that
was done in the u.s and we looked at the
same thing we broke it down by sepsis
and lrti and what you can see is reduced
overall antibiotic days of therapy
almost six days so very significant
again when we looked at c difficile
infection 16 16 000 we looked at
antibiotics 333 dollars
we looked at mechanical ventilation
costs 2100
86 for lab testing and 11 thousand three
hundred ten dollars overall
the same thing with lower respiratory
tract infections almost a five day
reduction that's very significant when
it's only eleven point nine to start
with
and then we looked at three different
cell infections very significant in this
population group because this involved a
lot of patients receiving lots of
antibiotics
and antibiotics again minus 290
mechanical inhalation minus 221
laboratory testing was kind of a wash it
was actually slightly higher in this
group and then overall
almost twenty nine hundred dollars
so very significant so
i would like to open it up to questions
now i will take any questions and
just send those in and we'll
we'll discuss those
thank you dr broyles for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now just click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
excuse me is
how will pct be used during flu season
yeah so that's a great question so in
flu season just like with covid the only
need for pct
the only need for antibiotics is if you
have a secondary bacterial infection so
the role of pct in flu season is simply
to rule out a secondary bacterial
infection the reason that's important is
patients who have a secondary bacterial
infection in covenant and seasonal
influenza have a 4.7
time
times greater likelihood of severity and
illness and doubt so the the role is
basically to rule out a secondary
bacterial infection and seasonal
influences in flu is generally much
higher as far as the rate than it is in
cuban 19.
all right thank you dr broyles the next
question is
what are other causes of elevated pct
sure that's a great question so there
there are things that elevate pct and
what you have to understand and i tell
people i think this is the easiest way
to look at it pct is elevated when
bacteria is where it doesn't belong okay
and by that what i mean by that is so if
you have a colon resection you get
bacteria in the peritoneal cavity it's
fairly common to have pct values around
one for the first day or two even in
patients who have
transplants so whether it be heart
lung kidney it's normal to have pct
values of two
up to ten in liver but they go down in
the next 48 hours in cytokine storm you
can actually have very large elevations
in pct and people say well the
inflammatory response drives that
elevation of pct
well it doesn't it doesn't so that is
due to an indirect response what happens
is in all these situations is you get
translocation of bacteria from places
that doesn't belong our lungs are full
of bacteria if you translocate bacteria
they get into the bloodstream our gut
we know very clearly that in ischemic
events hugely inflammatory responses
that that a lot of bacteria gets
translocated and the same thing with the
liver there's a lot of bacteria there so
those are some situations stills what uh
cells wagner's good pastures onco those
are autoimmune responses where you can
see elevations of pct and the normal
value is 0.5 versus 0.05
the same thing in people who are on
dialysis 30 percent of procalcitonin is
excreted greenly the remaining 70 is
enzymatically degraded so a normal value
in pct in those patients is going to be
0.5 or less you just simply have a new
value so you just think in terms of what
causes pct
to be elevated you can you can and
there's obviously a lot of situations
where
where that can happen because of the
inflammatory response
next question
we're having some audio trouble with our
moderator here i'm just going to go on
to the next question i see
is there utility for pct in the
diagnosis of
neonatal sepsis
yeah this is a great question so what
this comes down to is this situation is
that is that um
after the first 48 hours pcp
values are exactly the same as they are
in adults
and they respond and the values are
exactly the same now what is interesting
is in that in the first 48 hours after
delivery pct values can be very high
and there's actually an algorithm that
you can go to that will tell you for
instance at 24 hours the pct value of 24
is normal and why that is simply you
have
an infant who is in a sterile
environment who is now put in a
situation where they're bombarded by
bacteria and so their body is actually
seeing bacteria that it's never seen
before and so in those situations you
literally can go to an algorithm and
know if it's elevated or not now it's
going to be high okay
but the algorithm will tell you and it
does provide value at the end of 48
hours pct will be normal and so it's
just kind of an interesting interesting
situation
all right thank you dr boyles our next
question here
let's see is there utility for you just
answered this one i believe for neonatal
uh pct and the diagnosis of neonatal
sepsis okay i'm sorry i had some
technical difficulties and had to log
back in so i'm catching up the next
question
how did added pct
adding pct to your existing order sets
help the physicians use this test
yeah so putting on the existing order
sets when used appropriately is going to
do several things it's going to tell
them is the bacterial infection because
it will not be elevated in viral
infections when the white count may be
through the roof or unelevated you never
know
it's going to tell them then based on
the level what's its initial severity
assessment
based on the second
pct test that's going to tell you
are your antibiotics working and then
also it can provide you with
opportunities to stop antibiotics sooner
and so a lot of information from one or
two pct values putting it into the order
sets makes sure that it gets ordered i
can tell you the other day we had a
patient that didn't get or i don't know
what happened we actually have them in
the order sets
and so
when i went to check on the patient
there was no pcp value and this was a
lung infection and you know it's in our
order set i don't know how it got taken
off but nonetheless the pct was 141.
well 141 in a lung infection is huge and
i can assure you that when we looked at
that patient from that point on our
impression of that patient was much
different than it was before so the key
is is that if you get those in your
order sets you routinely get pcts
ordered you routinely look at them and
you routinely have an opportunity to act
on the test value
all right thank you dr boyles
our next question here
can you share insights on how the
education helped physicians did it help
to shift their position on pct utility
sure well yes so
um human nature is is that
we tend not to believe anything that
seems too good to be true i mean and so
one of the things that you run into is
if somebody came from a situation and
say they didn't use pct
and and they just did what came where
wherever they came from so that's one of
those situations is that people say well
i didn't use it well why didn't you use
it well i don't know i just didn't use
it and so
what you have to do is you have to
provide enough evidence that they can
trust the test so what we did is we had
uh i did noon luncheon so that was one
of the things that was common because my
physicians don't like to do dinners and
so we did noon luncheons and we had
multiple presentations i think i had
three the first time
when we were initiating the the test and
then what i did is i turned over to them
and had them do case studies well now
the thing is if it's a case study they
want theirs to be better than somebody
else but you have to get them to use the
test until they get the ah-ha moment the
first all-home moment that they'll get
is is when the patient's not doing well
and pct goes up and they'll change it
and then they'll see it going down
the second aha moment is when they
realize that they can actually stop
sooner
when they didn't think they could but
you know the education component you you
know because everybody's looking for a
reason just to do what they've always
done and for them it's always easier to
just give more antibiotics unfortunately
that's not what is what is in the best
interest of our patients in in them and
hospitals
thank you dr boyles our next question
here
do you know how many pct tests on
average are done per patient when
standardizing a pct testing protocol
like this and how often do you recommend
do do how often do you recommend doing
them
yeah so that depends on where you're at
so we averaged in the data that i
presented as far as our clinical
outcomes we actually
3.1 pcts
now
what i would suggest is is that we
handle icu versus non-icu slightly
differently so our link to stay in
non-ic patients is 2.9 days
so what we actually did is our protocol
says we get one daily so that could be
four okay
now what we do is though is that in
situations where we have two negative
pcts then we cancel the remaining tests
so we don't just continue you know to
order the test but we put those in there
just to make sure that they don't get
missed so that they're available for
rounds
now icu is a different story you know we
will always do two and then we'll just
do those as needed if that if that makes
sense but um
generally you know two or three what i
would suggest if you have people that
have community acquired pneumonia super
exacerbations or sepsis you get the
first two
you know kinetically it's going to go
down by about half every day the pct
value and so then you know when to order
that last pct which will then be the 80
reduction so you can generally get by
with three tests in most situations
thank you again dr broyles our next
question here
is there the potential to reduce or use
other lab tests differently for example
what do you recommend for the repeat
frequency for cbc and differential
possibly daily and also same question
for lactate
yeah so that is a great question so
lactate's its own marker it's really not
affected lactate is simply a marker or
perfume perfusion
but now if you think in terms of the
white count um
really
you know
you have the opportunity to not order as
many white counts because the pct once
you determine to be bacterial you have
the opportunity maybe to consider not
doing as many now i think a lot of our
clinicians go ahead and order one anyway
but i don't really understand why we do
that there's really not a need for that
i think there's an opportunity um we
kind of do the same thing obviously
we're going to get blood cultures the
way we are but there are studies that
have indicated
that if pct is 0.5 or less
there's probably no need to do a blood
culture
but you know
that's just an opportunity
all right thanks again dr broyles
we've got uh one more question here
do you think
do you think you will need to follow up
um
training for physicians and if so what
time point
well the answer is absolutely yes so
what i do is two things i look at where
it was i will have training if it gets
used inappropriately
and then we have training when we bring
new people in
so we actually have a video we put it on
a uh we made a video so that they can
actually watch it and they can go
through that to
to familiarize ourselves particularly in
the ed so we have a lot of you know ed
physicians that rotate through and so we
provide that for them and then the
hospitals we we provide that for them to
to look at but the answer is yes i mean
the continuing education never goes away
i mean you would want it to you would
hope it would but you always bring it in
people that are not familiar and what i
do is again is if they're using it
inappropriately then it's time for
education
great thank you again dr broyles looks
like that was all we had time for do you
have any final comments for our audience
before we go
no i just uh i just hope that you give
it a chance and that you look at it it's
a huge a huge test
you know and cost effective i mean you
know i it depends what you know your
contract pricing is but the test with 15
ish dollars
um
you know it's it's very cost effective
and it can make a huge difference i mean
we did ever we did laboratory
optimization started back in 1992
and we we did everything that we knew to
do with the laboratory testing and pct
still reduced standard iqs 49 so that's
huge
and once you get to use it you'll never
go with anywhere without it every time i
have a physician that leaves the first
thing i do is i get it they get called
me up and they said would you do
education for us for pct we need to
bring it on here and that's what happens
when you use it you'll develop a great
deal of confidence in your tests and you
don't want to be without it because it
definitely can make a huge difference
thank you again to our speaker dr mike
broyles for your time today and for your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye